how does your conception of geographical
and transfer frontiers apply to the rest
of the natural world
i can see how the dynamics of the
geographical frontier could be similar
but cannot intuitively apply transfer
frontiers
so this actually fits perfectly with the
previous question
so you know what um in what way could we
argue that
other organisms besides humans engage in
in markets
or in exchange that looks like markets
uh you know just
famously to use the one that that
titillates is sex for food trades
in bonobos right yeah the so-called
pikmi champs sister taxon to chimps
uh and when and you know and and
so-called nuptial gifts
are present from you know spiders and
wasps and you know all
all over the animal kingdom in which in
order to get access
uh usually to a female a male must
supply a gift of some sort usually food
sometimes his own
body um and and that is
that's a kind of market right that is an
exchange uh that is not
a for a but a for b and uh there's going
to be constant negotiation between each
player in terms of
whether or not um they think they're
getting a good deal and no it's not
conscience conscious when it spiders and
to some degree some of it's going to be
in bonobos some of it will be conscious
but not as fully conscious as it is in
humans and of course a lot of the traits
that we do aren't conscious and we think
because we use language we put this
conscious wording on things
and then we forget all the stuff that's
happening below the surface because we
think our words are our truths and
they're not
yeah um i agree with this and one of the
reasons
that um we talk about mating and dating
markets is that this really isn't
conscious people are involved
in uh market-like exchanges even when
they're
they find that terminology abhorrent but
somebody who
is versed in the technolo and the
terminology can just map it on there
very very easily but here's the thing
you know you've got lots of examples
that we can find uh within
humans in places that we don't expect it
within other creatures
um in close context like uh
you know bonobos within their group and
all but if you're willing to look
between species
the stuff is everywhere right every
one of these insect or animal pollinated
systems
fruit distribution you know creatures or
even
oh so so so what you're talking about is
you know a bee comes to a flower
and gets uh gets nectar and exchange
carries gametes to the next flower so
clear trade but even something like
mixed foraging
flocks of different bird species one of
whom is
helping find the food and the other of
whom is better at alerting against
predators like that's a kind of exchange
as well oh of course
and you know frankly if you and i were
to just set about
the task we could probably
come up with example after example until
we literally
fell asleep at the microphone because
you don't want to see that
no you don't yeah no and
market forces will prevent us from doing
that because it wouldn't be a good
strategy
however i mean look we've got
even just you right you are
yeah you all are you um you are
um simultaneously an
individual and a
colony of gut flora and you know
other creatures that live in some of
them eating right now well not anymore
um but uh you know your gut flora
are part of a partnership in which they
get something
and um you very definitely get something
the ability to live
because of their activity in your gut
and even
even yourselves your cells
are the composite
of two distinct creatures right your
mitochondria were at one point
free living creatures who took up
residence inside
of cells that became eukaryotic so
you're not even
one creature you're a partnership at the
level of 30 trillion cells each of which
have these
uh little once autonomous creatures
within them
uh you know we've got networks of um
fungi that allow plants to
um uh extract nutrients from
their soil environment and there's an
exchange of resources there
the exchanges are everywhere and
um anyway a little imagination reveals
just how
broad a concept it is yeah so i think um
we
we did not actually answer the question
what was the question which was about
transfer frontiers
oh and where we see transfer frontiers
in in non-humans and i think basically
anytime
uh you see theft of resource or uh which
often manifests as territoriality um
that's
that's effectively a kind of transfer
frontier you know we're talking within
species
um well gosh not even like i can think
of just from from my own research i had
i had
one frog species moving in and stealing
stealing
a place in which to rear his his babies
from another frog species
and uh once done there was no using that
resource again until the
second frog species had raised his kids
and moved on yep
so nectar thieves nectar thieves oh yeah
hummingbirds that go in at the base of
the flower rather than going in where
they're supposed to and so get the
nectar but don't pollinate
absolutely they're beautiful but they're
diabolical yes i mean nasty
nasty hummingbirds i'm a big fan of
hummingbirds but yes they do
all sorts of creatures steel and in fact
i have bad news for you animals we're
stuck with it
all right we we are not autotrophic
right and even those you might be
thinking but corals are autotrophic no
they're not because they might need to
define your terms uh generating their
own
food so plants are generating uh
carbohydrate
from sunlight and co2 in the atmosphere
they're literally taking
air and turning it into sugar and
cellulose
using energy from the sun like that's
the honest way to do it so autotrophic
self-feeding effectively versus
heterotrophic other feeding which is
what we are
yeah so basically no matter what kind of
animal you are you're stealing
those uh resources from some
animal or some plant and ultimately if
you chase things
these things down far enough it has to
come from some autotroph
almost all of which are plants which are
generating these things through
photosynthesis so
you know um do we still call it a
transfer frontier
if it's been going on for so long that
it's just the way things function i'm
you know
it's kind of a distinction without a
difference but anyway
uh is it a perfect match maybe not maybe
uh maybe it's just
easier when you're talking about um
human populations but
it you know if you back off the
tolerances just
slightly it maps very well
[Music]
you